it is 11 a.m. on a workday let's do this
[Music]
I'm already getting an Adam Levine's
I've done this I don't move II really I
don't know why I'm interested yes not
terrible
that's like get you fired up for a fight
no if somebody like bought you this is a
shot yeah you could like finish it wrap
you up I want to say it's Justin
Timberlake I'm gonna go with JT this
tastes a little bit like jay-z I could
imagine jay-z sippin on this after like
Beyonce's yelled at him a little bit
this smells like them
[Music]
it smells like straight sugar I think
this is Nikki even before I taste it
because it looks elegant hmm
whoa what the [ __ ] has a way too sweet
there's no category that this excels it
just tastes like an apple crown this
tastes like Nicki Minaj if this is Kanye
I'm gonna cry it certainly reminds me of
the Queen yeah Nicki no you know better
no knowing those Nicki Minaj I
definitely like it more oh it smells
like ranch dressing I smell like ranch
dressing
this smells like tequila wow this is
great
it's really smooth it's flavorful I
would be definitely drinking this at a
pool party which head would you like
whoa this is a visionary liquor Konya is
a visionary man that's a face you make
when you turn it into peeler Justin your
tequila's a lot like you it looks white
but then there's a nice little kick at
the end Justin just does everything
right yeah this is gonna suck it smells
like a Yankee Candle you know what this
smells like exactly what a push pop yeah
Oh terrible aftertaste this event
watermelon II this tastes like the
equivalent of seeing like a 14 year old
kid smoking a cigarette
I hope it's P Diddy like it would be
hilarious if this is P Diddy's alcohol
funky and sugary with just a hint of
spice I'm doing Nicki Minaj city would
make he makes these drinks for women you
know what this was probably inspired by
JLo oh that is its like feet and rubbing
alcohol
smells like college party vodka it has a
sweetness to it that my face would
indicate otherwise normally vodka is
like a chore but this is like right
there like it's either Kanye Pharrell
I would I would have to agree it's gotta
be easy that would be easy what dan
Aykroyd look at this he's never been
with a cooler group of people in this
entire life though I don't know why I
thought these would be different from
normal liquors like oh there's celebrity
liquors no this just looks like whisky
it has it's a celebrity face on it the
only occasions where would make sense
for me to drink be in the future would
be if the actual celebrity was plenty of
themselves yes if I had a lot of money I
would make my own alcohol too